[Musique
] c'était la nuit avant les
vacances de Noël
et le plaisir battait son plein tu as divisé
notre famille en deux vols séparés maman
c'est s'il te plait que la famille soit partie pour leurs
grandes vacances c'est que tout le monde les
voitures partent maintenant mais j'ai oublié une petite
chose maman
papa  oncle blake
ils ne savent même pas que je suis ici
ma mère et mon père sont allés à tokyo je suis
totalement seul
tu réalises que mon fils de dix ans
est à la maison par  lui-même, vous venez de supposer que
Max était sur l'autre vol, nous n'avons pas
fait de recensement,
nous avons reçu des rapports de personnes suspectes
autour de 36 lincoln,
je ne peux pas aller en prison, chérie, je ne durerais pas
30 secondes en gen pop, c'est là que le
poisson frais arrive  il n'y a personne ici
et nous sommes des criminels je ne pense pas que
ce soit ma maison je dois la défendre
poche centrale à rayures orange
[musique]
qui ne sonnait pas bien
j'essaie de rentrer à la maison avec mon fils
qui est seul
et effrayé
et il a besoin de sa mère
[Musique]
oui je te